>>> ALL RIGHT, LET'S BRING IN
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN ADAM
KINZINGER OF ILLINOIS.
HE SERVES ON THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE.
HE'S ALSO ON THE HOUSE FOREIGN
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE.
SIR, THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US
THIS MORNING.
WHAT IS THIS SIGNALING TO YOU
THAT CIPOLLONE HAS BEEN
SUBPOENAED?
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU ABOUT
WHERE DOJ IS GOING HERE?
>> WELL, I DON'T -- AGAIN, I
DON'T KNOW THIS -- YOU GUYS
REPORTED IT, I'M SURE IT'S TRUE.
I HAVEN'T HEARD THIS FROM THE
COMMITTEE'S PERSPECTIVE JUST
GENERALLY I'LL SAY THIS IS
PROBABLY BAD FOR PRESIDENT --
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THIS IS -- IF HE GOES IN FRONT
OF THE GRAND JURY, IT SHOWS THAT
THIS IS MORE THAN, YOU KNOW,
WHAT DID JOHN EASTMAN DO, THE
ATTORNEY THAT BASICALLY CAME UP
WITH THAT CRAZY SCHEME TO
OVERTURN THE ELECTION, AND IT
PROBABLY IS A VERY DEEP INTEREST
ON WHAT THE PRESIDENT DID.
I THINK IN TERMS OF THEIR
NEGOTIATIONS, OBVIOUSLY THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT KNOWS BETTER
WHAT THEY CAN IN ESSENCE GET
AROUND WHEN IT COMES TO SAYING
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
AND SO I HOPE THEY, YOU KNOW, GO
AT THAT JUDICIOUSLY.
I HOPE PAT CIPOLLONE ACTUALLY
JUST TELLS THE TRUTH.
I HAVE NO DOUBT HE HASN'T.
BUT THERE IS NO REASON TO
PROTECT PARTICULARLY CRIMINAL
BEHAVIOR, WHAT COULD POTENTIALLY
BE CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR BEHIND
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
SO WE'LL SEE WHERE IT GOES.
BUT THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT THIS
INVESTIGATION HAS DEVELOPED
FURTHER ALONG THAN WHERE WE KNEW
IT WAS OR THOUGHT IT WAS A FEW
MONTHS AGO.
>> IS CIPOLLONE AN AREA WHERE
THE COMMITTEE AND DOJ ARE
COOPERATING?
>> I'M NOT GOING TO GET INTO
THAT.
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE SHARED 20
TRANSCRIPTS OF DOJ.
WE HAVE AN OPEN CONVERSATION
WITH THEM, BUT I'M NOT GOING TO
GET INTO THE DETAILS OF ANY OF
THAT.
>> CNN IS REPORTING THE PENTAGON
WIPED THE PHONES OF TOP
DEPARTING OFFICIALS AT THE END
OF THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
THEY DELETED ANY TEXTS FROM KEY
WITNESSES.
THIS IS AN INITIAL COURT FILING,
OF COURSE, THAT WAS IN MARCH,
THAT WAS ASKING FOR THIS
INFORMATION.
WHY DIDN'T THE COMMITTEE KNOW
ABOUT THIS BEFORE?
>> SEE, I DON'T KNOW.
I THINK I'M ALMOST MORE
INTERESTED IN WHY WE DIDN'T KNOW
THAN EVEN WHY THESE MESSAGES
WERE DELETED, THOUGH, OF COURSE,
WE'RE QUITE INTERESTED IN THAT.
YOU KNOW, WE MADE IT CLEAR WHAT
WE WERE INTERESTED IN READING,
PARTICULARLY WITH THE SECRET
SERVICE.
WE KNEW THAT THERE WERE TEXTS WE
NEEDED TO SEE.
AND, YOU KNOW, WE FIND OUT THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL KNEW MONTHS
PRIOR TO EVEN WHEN HE TOLD US HE
KNEW ABOUT MISSING TEXTS.
SO I DON'T NECESSARILY KNOW IF
THIS IS SOME MASSIVE COVER-UP.
IT CERTAINLY STINKS TO HIGH
HEAVEN, BUT IN THE WORST CASE IT
ISURE TO FOLLOW
THROUGH ON RECORDS KEEPING.
THAT IN ITSELF IS AN ACT THAT
NEEDS FOLLOWED THROUGH ON.
LOOK, WE HAVE THE -- ONE OF THE
MOST INTENSE DAYS FOR THE U.S.
MILITARY AND PARTICULARLY FOR
THE SECRET SERVICE SINCE 9/11.
THE IDEA THAT YOU WOULD GO
THROUGH THEN A TECHNOLOGY
MITIGATION OR MIGRATION AND BE,
LIKE, YEAH, I DON'T CARE IF YOU
DELETE ALL YOUR TEXTS FROM THE
TWO MOST -- ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT DAYS AS FAR AS THE
SECRET SERVICE IS CONCERNED, IT
DOESN'T REALLY MAKE A LOT OF
SENSE TO ME.
>> WHERE ARE YOU GUYS ON WORKING
TO TRY TO RECOVER SOME OF THAT,
WORKING WITH FORENSIC, YOU KNOW,
TECHNICIANS WHO MIGHT HAVE SOME
INSIGHT INTO THIS?
HAVE YOU MADE ANY HEADWAY THERE?
>> WELL, WE'RE CERTAINLY TRYING,
BUT, I MEAN, I THINK -- I THINK
IT IS -- NOT THAT WE'RE GOING TO
LET UP, BUT I'M NOT SURE TO WHAT
EXTENT WE CAN GET THIS STUFF
BACK.
I KNOW WE'RE ASKING THE
QUESTIONS AND TRYING TO FIGURE
THAT OUT AS MANY ARE, BUT IT IS
POSSIBLE IT IS JUST GONE.
AND, YOU KNOW, IF SOMEBODY
INTENDS TO MAKE SOMETHING GO
AWAY, IT CAN GO AWAY.
>> YOU'RE NOT HOPEFUL.
YOU'RE NOT HOPEFUL YOU'RE GOING
TO GET ANY OF THIS.
>> WELL, I DON'T KNOW.
I JUST DON'T KNOW WHAT TO BE
HOPEFUL WITH THIS OR NOT.
HERE IS WHAT I AM HOPEFUL FOR AT
LEAST, SOMEBODY COMES FORWARD
AND TELLS US WHAT THEY KNOW.
IF THERE IS SOMEBODY KNOWS FOR
INSTANCE THESE WERE
INTENTIONALLY ERASED, THAT'S
YOUR DUTY AS AN AMERICAN TO COME
FORWARD AND SAY SOMETHING.
IF YOU KNOW, LET'S BE HONEST, IF
YOU KNOW IT WAS JUST AN
ACCIDENT, THEN WE NEED TO KNOW
THAT TOO.
THAT'S OBVIOUSLY SOMETHING THAT
SEEMS KIND OF FISHY, BUT IT'S
POSSIBLE.
LET'S BE HONEST.
I'M A LITTLE MORE CONFIDENT THAT
SOMEBODY WILL COME FORWARD AND
TELL US SOMETHING THAT WE DON'T
KNOW WITH THAT, THAN I AM THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
RECOVER IT.
BUT WE'RE CERTAINLY TRYING.
>> I KNOW YOU'RE CLOSELY
WATCHING THESE PRIMARY ELECTIONS
AS WE ALL WERE LAST NIGHT.
YOU CALLED IT DISGUSTING.
HERE ON THIS PROGRAM, THAT
DEMOCRATS WERE HELPING ELEVATE
ELECTION DENIERS IN THE HOPES
THAT THEY WOULD BE EASIER TO
DEFEAT IN A GENERAL AGAINST A
MORE MODERATE REPUBLICAN.
ONE OF THE MODERATES IN THE RACE
IS PETER MEIJER WHO LOST HIS
PRIMARY.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION?
>> YEAH, I MEAN, IT'S -- YOU
KNOW, IF PETER'S OPPONENT WINS
AND GOES ON TO NOVEMBER AND
WINS, THE DEMOCRATS OWN THAT.
CONGRATULATIONS.
HERE IS THE THING.
DON'T KEEP COMING TO ME ASKING
WHERE ARE ALL THE GOOD
REPUBLICANS THAT DEFEND
DEMOCRACY AND THEN TAKE YOUR
DONOR'S MONEY AND SPEND HALF A
MILLION DOLLARS PROMOTING ONE OF
THE WORST ELECTION DENIERS THAT
IS OUT THERE.
THE DCCC NEEDS TO BE ASHAMED OF
THEMSELVES.
SOME MEMBERS OF CONGRESS,
DEMOCRATS HAVE SPOKEN OUT AND
SAID THEY'RE DISGUSTED.
I RESPECT IT.
I HAVE SPOKEN OUT AGAINST THE
NATIONAL REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSIONAL COMMITTEE MANY
TIMES WHEN THEY HAVE DONE THINGS
I'VE DISAGREED WITH AND THERE
ARE ALSO PEOPLE WHO SAY THIS IS
JUST POLITICS, HOW CYNICAL THAT
IS, AND THAT'S WHY THE AMERICANS
ARE JUST SICK OF BOTH PARTIES TO
BE HONEST WITH YOU.
>> I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT THE
SPEAKER'S TRIP TO TAIWAN.
YOU'RE SEEING CHINA RESPOND.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> LOOK, I GOT TO SAY, THAT WAS
COURAGEOUS OF THE SPEAKER TO DO.
SHE DESERVES CREDIT.
I WAS CONCERNED THAT, YOU KNOW,
AFTER THIS KIND OF PRESSURE
MOUNTED THAT SHE WOULD BACK OFF
AND SHE WENT THROUGH AND SHE IS
TOUGH IN DOING THAT.
AND SHE HAD TO DO IT.
LOOK, CHINA IS GOING TO TRY TO
LOOK TOUGH.
I DON'T THINK THEY WANT TO
ESCALATE.
I THINK MR. XI IS RUNNING AGAIN
AND HE WANTS TO BASICALLY SEND A
MESSAGE TO THE COMMUNIST PARTY.
BUT, LOOK, THIS IS IMPORTANT FOR
US AS A COUNTRY TO RECOGNIZE.
STRENGTH, WHEN YOU DO SOMETHING
OUT OF STRENGTH, IT ACTUALLY
MAKES CONFLICT LESS LIKELY.
AND BY NANCY PELOSI FOLLOWING
THROUGH AND GOING TO TAIWAN, SHE
SENT A MESSAGE WE WILL NOT BE
INTIMIDATED.
I WISH, FRANKLY, THE
ADMINISTRATION HAD SENT THAT
MESSAGE INSTEAD OF SAYING WE
DON'T WANT HER TO GO.
BUT THAT SAID, SHE DID AND IT
WAS, I THINK, A GOOD MOMENT FOR
THE UNITED STATES.
>> AFTER THIS VISIT, AS YOU SAY,
A GOOD MOMENT FOR THE UNITED
STATES IN YOUR OPINION, CLOSER
TO ANY SORT OF CONFRONTATION
WITH CHINA?
DO YOU THINK THE U.S. IS CLOSER?
>> I THINK WE'RE CLOSER EVERY
DAY.
I DON'T THINK IT IS NECESSARILY
RELATED TO THIS.
IT IS RELATED TO CHINA'S DESIRE
TO TAKE TAIWAN.
IT IS LIKE RUSSIA AND UKRAINE.
AND SO, YEAH, I THINK EVERY DAY
WE'RE CLOSER.
I THINK FRANKLY CONFLICT IS VERY
LIKELY.
NOT NECESSARILY IN THE NEAR
FUTURE, BUT AT SOME POINT IN THE
FUTURE.
THIS IS WHY STANDING UP WITH
STRENGTH AND MAKING IT CLEAR
THAT HE WILWE WILL DEFEND OUR F
IS IMPORTANT TO MITIGATE THAT
POSSIBILITY.
>> HOW ARE YOU SEEING THE U.S.
YESTERDAY TAKING OUT THE LEADER
OF AL QAEDA IN KABUL?
OBVIOUSLY A VERY SUCCESSFUL
OPERATION, AND YET THERE HE WAS
IN KABUL, CERTAINLY SENDS A
MESSAGE TO AL QAEDA THEY'RE NOT
SAFE IN KABUL, BUT WHAT IS THE
TAKEAWAY FOR YOU ABOUT THE
SAFETY OF THE U.S.?
>> I THINK THE TAKEAWAY IS WE'RE
A LITTLE SAFER WITH ZAWAHIRI
DEAD.
I ALSO WANT TO SAY TO ANY OF THE
PEOPLE I HEARD IN MY PARTY THAT
ARE, LIKE, SOMEHOW SAYING THAT
THIS ISN'T A BIG DEAL, JUST SHUT
UP AND BE AN AMERICAN FOR ONE
DAY.
YOU KNOW, THIS IS A GOOD DEAL.
NOW, WHAT IS THE BAD OF THIS?
CERTAINLY THE TALIBAN OR
ELEMENTS OF THE TALIBAN
COMPLETELY UNSURPRISINGLY TO ME
AND I GUESS COMPLETELY
UNSURPRISINGLY TO THE
ADMINISTRATION, I HEARD AN
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIAL SAY
YESTERDAY, OH, YEAH, WE KNEW
THAT THERE WAS GOING TO BE A
RELATIONSHIP, BUT OBVIOUSLY THE
TALIBAN AND AL QAEDA ARE BACK IN
BED.
WE SHOULDN'T BE SURPRISED AT
THAT.
WE HAVE REALLY BEEN HAMPERED IN
OUR ABILITY TO FIGHT TERRORISM.
WE CAN DO VERY GOOD TACTICAL
THINGS LIKE KILL A MAN, IF WE
KNOW WHERE HE IS.
BUT THE STRATEGIC IMPLICATIONS
OF WHAT WE CAN DO IN
COUNTERTERRORISM, BUILDING
ALLIANCES, DENYING AREA TO AN
ENEMY, KNOWING WHAT THEIR PLANS
ARE, THAT HAS BEEN MASSIVELY
HAMPERED.
LET'S CELEBRATE THIS WIN.
I'M GLAD HE'S DEAD.
BUT LET'S GO INTO THIS EYES WIDE
OPEN.
YOU GOT TO STAY ON THE OFFENSE
OF THE BIGGEST TERRORISTS.
THEY HAVE NOT CHANGED THEIR
OPINION.
THEY HAVEN'T CHANGED THEIR MIND.
THEY STILL WANT TO DO WHAT THEY
DID ON 9/11.
>> CONGRESSMAN KINZINGER, IT IS
GREAT TO HAVE YOU THIS MORNING,
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.